todos nós indistintamente todos nesse
auditório e remotamente qualquer ser
humano neste planeta
ou nós conhecemos circunstâncias alheias
ou nós passamos por situações onde nós
vamos dizer não consigo perdoar
estou magoado fiquei ressentido e o
oposto disso
indivíduos com resignação com um bom
enfrentamento gratidão
enfim sentimentos identificar o que isto
tem a ver com a ciência
o que isso tem a ver com a pesquisa ou
melhor com o adoecimento do coração dois
pontos tudo tudo e nessa jornada de
alguns minutos nós vamos compartilhar
com vocês
idéias que a ciência tem que se ocupar
para eventualmente traçarmos sugestões
transformadoras para nossa saúde com
base no modelo que anteriormente não
havia sido pensado dentro do cenário
brasileiro em 2017 ocorreram 1 milhão
duzentos e setenta e um mil óbitos
um terço desses óbitos
a causa doença cardiovascular enfarto
que o ataque cardíaco com e o acidente
vascular cerebral que o famigerado
derrame
por que que isso acontece porque que a
sociedade apresenta esse encurtamento da
sobrevida por meio da doença
o lar tem um modelo muito bom muito
prático que explicam nossa do e cimento
é chamado de transição epidemiológica o
indivíduo sai da zona rural ou de uma
cidade pacata pequena e vai para a
cidade uma cidade mais agitada
quando isso acontece o benefício inicial
é claro vacina sanitas ão mas a partir
da vida nesse ambiente tóxico
nós passamos alterar a nossa alimentação
sedentarismo tabagismo e até esses três
vocês devem estar pensando eu já sabia
não está falando nada de novo e vem um
quarto elemento forte carga estressoras
seja no ambiente doméstico seja na
sociedade seja no trabalho
a partir destes fatores que nós chamamos
fatores de risco
com o passar do tempo a chegar a pressão
alta diabetes obesidade e alteração do
colesterol ingredientes perfeitos para
que num determinado momento aquele
produto encomendado por nós
chegará que é o evento cardiovascular
o infarto e um derrame acidente vascular
cerebral
se vocês olharem nesse mapa a área azul
no brasil significa que não está tudo
azul significa aumento nas taxas de
morte por infarto
não está havendo redução por mais que
vocês ouçam novidades tecnológicas ou de
genética não está havendo redução da
morte por doença cardiovascular em
países em desenvolvimento onde o brasil
está e com base nisso nós avançamos um
pouco mais pra entender o que é que está
associado ou quais são os fatores
se associam com o ataque cardíaco e por
meio de uma colaboração de 52 países o
brasil faz parte
nós identificamos nove fatores de risco
que são responsáveis por 90% do risco de
infarto
não tem nada de genética não tem nada de
fatores absolutamente inovadores coisas
simples como pressão alta colesterol
cigarro diabetes obesidade abdominal
falta de frutas e legumes na alimentação
sedentarismo
mas eu chamo atenção para o fator
psicossocial que é o nome pomposo para o
stress e para depressão que não estão
mostrando bem o que está acontecendo mas
nós podemos olhar nesse gráfico de pizza
que 33%
está como 32,5 33 por cento do risco
associado ao infarto tem a ver com
estresse e depressão
equivale a dizer que se nós gerenciamos
estresse depressão
se nós melhorarmos o nosso enfrentamento
na nossa vida de relacionamento conosco
mesmos com a família no trabalho e na
sociedade
nós evitaríamos um terço do total de
infartos portanto 400 mil infartos por
ano no brasil um terço seria mais ou
menos 140 mil a menos
mas olhando estresse e depressão
nós temos que pensar o seguinte o
pesquisador
sempre tem que duvidar daquilo que ele
está fazendo
tem que deixar pelo menos 10% dele
dizendo assim tudo isso aqui não é
suficiente para explicar por que
adoecemos porque temos ataque cardíaco
porque que temos derrame e pensando
assim vem aquela palavra da mudança do
modelo que explica o adoecimento
o que nós temos hoje é muita tecnologia
para tentar compensar o complementar o
modelo que talvez não explique
apropriadamente porque o indivíduo
adoece especificamente do ponto de vista
cardiovascular e nessa linha
nós temos o fator chamado
espiritualidade o silêncio é
espiritualidade e nesse ponto eu preciso
definir o que não é espiritualidade
quando falamos em religião é um sistema
de crenças dogmas práticas que o ser
humano quando tem tenta acessar o que é
sagrado transcedental não é sobre isso
que estou falando
temos a religiosidade que o quanto o
indivíduo atende segue a religião que
escolheu que pode ser organizacional vai
a um templo religioso ou pode ser não
organizacional faz leituras pertinentes
e ora reflete sobre a própria vida
espiritualidade tem outra definição que
eu colocarei duas para vocês uma delas
que é da doutora puchalski que diz que é
parte intrínseca e dinâmica do ser
humano portanto todos nós temos
independente de crença independente de
presença ausência de religião e que
através da qual o indivíduo procura
propósito e sentido na vida que envolve
relacionamento consigo e com os outros
nós temos um grupo de estudos em
espiritualidade medicina cardiovascular
dentro da sociedade brasileira de
cardiologia 850 cardiologistas e nós
propusemos uma outra definição que
espiritualidade é o estado mental e
emocional
se preferirem espiritual que norteia os
nossos pensamentos atitudes e ações e
aquilo que mais mostra como somos
reações durante a nossa vida de
relacionamento de novo e
pedi da média relacionamento nós conosco
mesmos com os outros e com a sociedade
dentro dessa linha da espiritualidade e
da religiosidade
nós fomos buscar a literatura até com um
pouco de ceticismo no início a
literatura médica científica ela é
relativamente abundante em publicações
sobre espiritualidade e religiosidade e
de que maneira isso é avaliado
questionários perguntas para os
indivíduos que são questionadas
validados inclusive dentro de nosso país
de maneira resumida espiritualidade e
religiosidade está associada com um
melhor controle de pressão arterial
menor risco cardiovascular menor
ocorrência de doença arterial coronária
que a placa de gordura na coronária
gerenciamento mais efetivo de estresse e
depressão
mas o mais interessante na última linha
associa-se com aumento na sobrevida
portanto atenua ou reduz mortalidade na
verdade não reduzimos a mortalidade a
gente só reagendá a data do evento
sempre teremos asseguro a todos mas o
reagendamento é possível podemos
reagendar e quando olhamos que esse
fator que inicialmente alguns cientistas
podem torcer o nariz e de maneira não
científica dizer é assim isso não ss
a ciência tem obrigação de investigar
isso aquilo foi comprovado pode
transformar a sociedade e algo que tem
sugestão de impacto na sobrevida é claro
que nós queremos observar é claro que
nós queremos olhar mais fundo porque se
isso realmente ocorre
nós temos que repensar porque estamos há
dois ano e como atenuar ou reduzir a
chance de adoecimento é uma pergunta
científica o ser humano tem que adoecer
e de morrer
não nós tivemos alguns exemplos
anteriores de peso de pessoas que
envelhecem
em um determinado momento é como se o
prazo de validade inspirasse mas ele não
adoeceu
a pressão vai caindo a temperatura vai
diminuindo mas o indivíduo falece morre
mas ele não passou pelo adoecimento que
encurtaria a sobrevida livre de eventos
mas eu chamo vocês pra propormos algo
novo e portanto pensamos no novo modelo
para explicar o adoecimento a literatura
traz coisas que nós não sabíamos que já
existia por exemplo pacientes que têm
doença coronária é a placa de gordura na
coronária é o infarto que o entupimento
dessa coronária esses indivíduos quando
tem prontidão ao perdão tem menor
quantidade de isquemia que o músculo
cardíaco sem sangue era então nós
estamos falando que perdão isso que
funciona ou é discutido em outros
ambientes
a medicina ea ciência está olhando isso
e quem tem mais prontidão ao perdão tem
menor chance diz que mia coronária
segundo indivíduos que têm o potencial
raivoso
provavelmente ninguém dentro dessa fala
é tem esse potencial explosivo mas não é
apenas essa questão de vai aumentar sua
pressão
isso pode lhe trazer um ataque cardíaco
temos maior ocorrência de diabetes
a partir de alguns anos no indivíduo que
tem mais raiva e não para por aí
o indivíduo colérico com raiva tem mais
chance na evolução de ter dilatação do
coração
o que nós estamos olhando é que essas
informações podem estar sugerindo uma
nova maneira de enxergar adoecimento e
como cientista eu digo esse nós até o
momento estivemos errado e tudo que está
sendo medido é um epifenômeno é um fator
a parte que o verdadeiro adoecimento
poderia ter vindo dessa maneira
e se pegarmos a totalidade dos estudos
que tenham questionário avaliando
religiosidade e espiritualidade tem
aquela redução nas taxas de mortalidade
olhando essas informações
nós temos que cada vez mais
insistimos na investigação perguntas mas
isso é função da ciência e só não seria
da religião
digo e reafirmo é função da sua
deficiência investigar porque parece que
segue uma linha diferente do habitual o
nosso processo de adoecimento falamos
então das virtudes ou de sentimentos
edificantes e aqui nós podemos encontrar
algum paralelo dentro da ética cristã da
ética judaica se preferirem outra
denominação que não tenha sugestão de
religião existe o chamado humanismo
secular quer fazer o bem porque é
importante fazer o bem
então essas virtudes e eu vou citar
algumas pra vocês perdão altruísmo
gratidão
nós temos questionários para que dentro
da ciência isso pode ser avaliado
se nós avaliamos isso dentro do ambiente
de adoecimento nós vamos chegar à
conclusão que provavelmente essas
virtudes podem prevenir adoecimento e
ausência delas trazer o adoecimento
portanto a ciência tem que olhar para
esse lado e eu devo confessar a vocês
que em 95 eu introduzir medicina baseada
em evidências no país
voltando o canadá que a medicina baseada
em comprovação científica é correto
assim o prático e assim deve ser agora
evidência científica tem que ser gerada
no início ela é promissora e depois
comprovada em sendo comprovado
nós temos que repensar como é que temos
que viver dentro da nossa sociedade
dentro deste ambiente de pesquisa têm um
estudo interessante que é um
questionário de religiosidade nas
enfermeiras americanas quase 75 mil
enfermeiras e essas enfermeiras
responder ao questionário
vários funcionários um deles tinha a ver
com religiosidade e elas foram seguidas
por décadas e no final na avaliação
aquelas que tinham uma maior utilização
de sentimentos para um enfrentamento
positivo das circunstâncias adversas do
dia a dia que todos nós somos expostos a
estas em comparação com aquelas que
absolutamente não utilizavam esse
enfrentamento positivo por meio desses
sentimentos quem tinha maior
religiosidade ou espiritualidade
apresentou menor morte por doença
cardíaca e menor morte por câncer
totalizando uma redução de morte por
qualquer causa eu tenha algo aqui que
nós precisamos investigar e é papel da
ciência e aqui eu digo e nós temos dados
para mostrar
não é por meio da genética fico contente
que já foi falado aqui o impacto é
mínimo da genética e talvez nós tenhamos
que debruçar sobre essas questões
ligadas à espiritualidade para
entendermos de maneira mais clara o
porquê do nosso adoecimento
portanto nós gostaríamos de concluir que
perdão pode sim fazer bem ao coração
o segundo ponto é fazer o bem do ponto
de vista esse sentimento edificantes
pode estar associado a menor chance de
doença cardiovascular ataque cardíaco e
derrame e vamos aguardar os próximos
anos para gerarmos mais evidências mais
informações para quem sabe nós temos
mais uma razão por que que o ser humano
tem que melhorar do ponto de vista de
relacionamento na sociedade consigo
mesmo especialmente dentro da família
muito obrigado de coração
[Aplausos]